هي فعلا مباراه تاريخيه لاسود الاطلس في
اول وصول لهم الى دور ربع النهائي من
نهائيات كاس العالم
المقاهي المغربيه باعتبارها المكان المفضل
التشجيع امتلات نحن نتواجد في مقهى 80% من
المقاعد محجوزه والجمهور مستعد منذ ساعات
الصباح الاولى ونحن على بعد اربع ساعات من
بدايه المباراه المغاربه كلهم حماس وتعطش
لانجاز تاريخيا اخر يقول المغاربه ما دام
اسود الاطلس تفوق على بطل كاس العالم في
دوره جنوب افريقيا 2010 فاليوم يمكن ايضا
الانتصار على المنتخب البرتغالي البرتغالي
هزمت المغرب في مونديال روسيا 2018 ولكنها
عن هزمت امام اسود
المكسيك 86 وكان ذلك انجاز تاريخي وقتها
لاسود الاطلس المغارب اليوم مساء
جدات امهات كل الفئات الاجتماعيه المغربيه
ستكون هنا في المغرب في كل المدن وق
المغرب اللاعب رقم 13 من اجل ان تكون
وراءه وليد الرجراجي ووليداته كما يقول
المغاربه من اجل ابعاد البرتغال عن
المونديال والان المغاربه اصبحت لديهم
حلاوه انتصار كل الذين سالتهم يرفضون منطق
ان ينهزم المغرب امام البرتغال يقولون ان
البرتغال ستكون في المتناول لان اسبانيا
كانت صعبه بكوكب من النجوم بحارس كبير
ولكن مع ذلك لويس الريكي ان هزم امام وليد
الرجراجي ننتظر ايضا مباراه تكتيكيه
بامتياز ننتظر ايضا هل سيغير في التشكيله
وايضا في همم مقدمه الهجوم ولكن بالتاكيد
ان ياسين بيقولوا الحارس العملاق
سيكون الورقه الرابحه خصوصا اذا وصلت
المباراه الى ضربات الترجيح نعم هي اعمال
كبيره على اسود الاطلسي اليوم لكن همم كيف
تعاطى الاعلام المغربي ايضا مع هذه
المباراه همم ما هي اراء المراقبين والف
والموحدين الرياضيين ايضا وما الذي يرجونه
ايضا من خلال هذا اللقاء ويتوقنا
عناوين الصحافه المغربيه
باليوم هو ايضا يوم للترققب للانتظار
لانجاز كروي مغربي وعربي وافري غير مسبوق
في تاريخ هذه المسابقه الاكبر في اللعبه
الصحافه المغربيه ودعت ثقتها بالكامل في
وليد الركراكي ولكنها طلبته بالتعامل بكل
واقعيه
وتدبير المباراه لاننا ايضا في هذه
المباركه منتخب مغربي سيواجه مدربا
البرتغاليه ذكيا تمكن من قلب الموازين في
مباراه دوري الثمن واهل بطريقه سهله وبحصه
ثقيله المنتخب البرتغالي الصحافه المغربيه
ايضا طلبت الجماهير المغربيه المتواجده في
الملعب في قطر او المتواجده في قطر ولم
تجد تذاكر وايضا طلبت الجماهير المغربيه
في كل المغرب ان تكون وراء المنتخب
المغربي الصحافه المغربيه تتحدث عن ربح
منتخب مغربي تاريخي سيمكنه ان يلعب ادوار
طلائعيه في كاس افريقيا في دوره كاس
العالم المقبله هنالك مكاسب تتحدث عن
الصحافه المغربيه وخصوصا مكسب المدرب
المغربي الذي تعتبر الصحافه المغربيه الان
اهم وانجح وافضل مدرب في تاريخ كره القدم
المغربيه نعم الدعم الشعبي واضحه للمنتخب
المغربي عادل كما تفضل لكن ماذا عن الدعم
الرسمي
هنالك دعم رسمي مغربي قوي يكفي التذكير
بان العاهل المغربي الملك محمد السادس
اتصل وهنا اسود الاطلس وخرج همم الى شوارع
العاصمه المغربيه الرباط وقام بجوله بعض
انتصار المغاربه على اسبانيا في دور الثمن
وحيا المواطنين المغاربه هنالك ايضا
مشاركه للشقيق العاهد المغربي الامير رشيد
ومشاركه الامير مولاي الحسن الذي هو ولي
العهد العائله الملكيه مع المغاربه تشجع
ايضا اسود الاطلس الحكومه المغربيه وفرت
كل ما يمكن توفيره لاسود الاطلس و هنالك
اعتراف من اللاعبين بان اقامه في قطر تتم
في ظروف جيده لديهم الدعم المادي المعنوي
اللوجيسي وايضا حضور فوزي لقجع الذي هو
رئيس الجامعه الملكيه المغربيه لكره القدم
من المنتظر وسنه تاكد من هذا بعد قليل هل
سيكون همم وفد حكومي مغربي رسمي مشارك في
تشجيع المنتخب المغربي في المنصه 100
هنالك ايضا حديث عن امكانيه تواجد احد
امراء العائله الملكيه المغربيه في قطر
نترقب هنالك بصراحه المغرب في كاس العالم
لديه دعم شعبي جماهيري مغربي وعربي
وافريقي وايضا دعم من العائله الملكيه
والعراسهم العاهل المغربي